hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the terms
that plays a very important role with
its stoic moral theory is that of the
indifferent and this is a translation of
the Greek diaspora which was already in
the Greek of the Stoics times a
technical term it's one of the many
terms that they created or developed so
that they could articulate what they
were trying to to say a bit better
within book 2 chapter 6 produces himself
great talk about indifference on the
authorial is a sort of orientation of
the person towards these indifference so
one of the keys distinctions that's
being made here is the indifference are
those things that are not goods and
they're not evils they're not good for
us they're not bad for us to that
they're they can't be perceived as good
and bad but that's just because we make
mistakes with respect to them and this
covers a lot of ground so really
everything here are your summits made
goods and the evils as such are those
things
within our power so you know whether we
have wealth or not it's not strictly
speaking anything good or bad money is
just money it's something that is in
itself indifferent it doesn't have a
value other than being able to be
exchanged for other things and those
things might be good things or there
might be bad things right so money by
itself doesn't have any intrinsic value
pleasure doesn't have any intrinsic
value for the Stoics that doesn't mean
that they say that pleasure is a bad
thing that would be to make it something
that's not indifferent right prestige or
position or what parties you get to go
to or how tall you are all the things
that have to do with your body those are
strictly speaking indifference as well
so there's quite a few things even death
is in a difference now where attitudes
towards these are not indifferent so our
attitudes are things that lie within our
power how we evaluate them how we
respond to them what we think of them
you know so for example to fear death it
is itself something that is bad right
but death itself is not something that
is bad but it is rather something that
is indifferent to fear the loss of
others who we love through death is a
bad thing but their deaths are not
strictly speaking again from a story
perspective bad things they're not good
things either so this requires a little
bit of mental adjustment you know and
we're going to see that you know well
strictly speaking many things are
indifferent there are more deities to
this but the key distinction here is
what is inner power what falls within
the scope of our Faculty of choice or
our moral purpose that is where a
genuine good and bad lie so everything
else is really a matter of a difference
and we want to cultivate an attitude
towards those things of regarding them
right at me as being indifferent if we
want to be stories that said some of the
indifference where this is some
backstory that can actu'ly find the
epictetus himself but something that
he's assuming some of these were
look at as being preferred some of them
being rejected that means that all of
the things being equal
for example wealth wealth is not by
itself a good thing but you know you can
do good things with wealth and if you
know if you can't choose between wealth
and not wealth wealth is being heard
poverty is something which is being
preferred against poor or rejected
health disease right it's better to have
a healthy body in certain respects not
an absolute way according to the Stoics
but you know these things are still
within the realm of the indifferent they
are not genuinely good or genuinely evil
Epictetus is also going to say this is
very important in this this chapter but
also something that he talks about in
many other places that are used the
crisis in Greek the the way in which we
orient ourselves towards the decisions
we make about the very fashion in which
we approach these and difference is not
itself indifferent it has important
implications for ourselves so just
because something is a matter of
indifference in itself that doesn't mean
that we should be as he says well over
and over again
careless towards it that we shouldn't
exhibit some sort of you know
carefulness or caution or attentiveness
we shouldn't sort withdrawing ourselves
from the world in such a way so the ad
doesn't matter to me that's not a really
stoic attitude the stoic pays attention
to the things that are indifferent that
are largely externals but they pay
attention to them in such a way as to
keep them within proper perspective so
you know to make it very you know
mundane would a stoic brush his teeth
yes a stoic would brush his teeth and he
would brush his teeth several times a
day
why not because having good teeth is in
it
self a wonderful thing you can live
without teeth right you know dentures
well you know if you've got teeth you
may as well take good care of them and
it's kind of a lackadaisical attitude
not to be doing that that is probably
going to you know in fact the rest of
your attitude towards other things
including things that are much closer to
yourself so you know what a stoic you
know when it comes to other matters of
hygiene with it with the stoic be
particularly concerned with what shower
gel they have probably now but what if
[ __ ] want to start take a shower
yes probably so and we can go on and on
and on if you sent before a stomach dish
you know they're probably not going to
say oh that I don't really like to eat
that or anything like that they'll eat
what you give them but does that mean
that if they go into a restaurant they
can't make a choice No so the way in how
do they talk to the waiter to the
circuit board so the way in which we use
things that are indifferent is extremely
important from the stoic perspective
because it actually does fall within the
realm of our Faculty of choice and it
forms who who we are
and you know to to dot a kind of oh I
don't care about any of that sort of
stuff not only is not a stoic attitude
it may conceal a sort of attachment to
those things to to reject them so so
some merrily away from you and to reject
you to pay attention to them is probably
a sign of them being treated as evils
not as indifference so you know in - in
Section sorry chapter five of book two
he talks about this in terms of
materials cooling the term that
originally meant wood and then comes to
me and material in the philosophical
sense the stuff that things are made of
right so if you think about situations
that we're in we don't control
everything that goes
the situation but we do have some matter
of control over what our part of the
situation yes so you know if I know for
example that another person has a bad
temper it's not totally within my
control whether they blow up at me when
I have to give them bad news but I can't
in fact think about how I'm going to
present the news to them and whether I'm
going to tell them well don't get upset
about it or not you know which is
probably going to provoke them that all
does lie within my control so the use of
that is important roles and
relationships are particularly important
for stoic ethics there's a whole video
just man if you want to see that core
concept video the the relationships
themselves are indifference I don't
choose the majority of the relationships
that I wind up in but it's not
indifferent how I approach it if I am a
child I have a choice whether I want to
be a child who fulfills my roles as a
child towards a parent or whether I want
to ignore those or even go against those
and stick to them or something like that
that's not indifferent the duties that
are incumbent upon me as an Avery as a
citizen as professor as pick whatever
you like as a husband those are within
my my faculty of choice I choose how I
respond to those whether I fulfill them
partly or entirely or in a slipshod
manner or don't do them at all or make
excuses all of them is up to me and so I
can cultivate an attitude of
indifference towards all these things
and still pay attention to them and
treat them the way that they ought to be
treated now all that sudden it's very
important with respect to this attitude
of indifference that things that are
genuinely indifferent we really do treat
as indifferent so we don't you know
allow ourselves for exam
people to get puffed up with pride when
somebody says that our appearance is
attractive or that were you know really
great to listen to or that you know they
can't wait for our new book to come out
or now they're really looking forward to
seeing us this weekend we don't we don't
allow that to swell our heads so to
speak because those things aren't
different how other people see us is a
difference how we respond to them that
does fall within our province and that's
not something that's a difference how
much money we have in our bank account
that's indifferent that's not something
that we have total control over the
economy could take a die at any moment
how we manage our money in the presence
that's not indifferent whether we have
money or not not a locus of absolute
good and evil how we manage that money
that is a one of those things that has
to do with the preferred you know some
spending your money in a good way prefer
spending your money in stupid ways
rejected right so indifference isn't
just a total withdrawal from everything
external for the self but it is focusing
on what is integral to the self and then
how the person responds to other things
treating that wasn't different but
treating them also as if they are
attitudes towards them does matter